oh
m
irène chaigneau propose voyage sans
passeport
c'est dans cette région du chili que se
tiennent des volcans dont certains sont
toujours en activité
le long de la frontière bolivienne ils
sont couverts de neige à leurs pieds
dans cette terre de décombres s'accroche
quelques touffes d'air c'est pourtant de
ce royaume de terre morte que le chili
tire la principale de ses richesses car
des mines de souffle pour se trouve en
haut des volcans dans des cratères et un
le campement les ouvriers est situé à
3000 m d'altitude
il donne accès à une chaîne sans fin de
petite benne transportant le soufre
bruch jusque dans la vallée
pour arriver à la mine proprement dite
située à 6000 m on n'en prenne seul
moyen de locomotion
car le sentir est enneigée presque toute
l'année ce fut pour gilbert luck la
partie la plus pénible du voyage à ces
hauteurs où l'atmosphère est d'une
pureté étonnant que l'oxygène fait de
plus en plus défaut ce monde d'oxygène
pour battre le coeur à 130 pulsations de
la minute que les hauts plateaux à 4000
mètres d'altitude le sol par endroits
est recouvert d'une croûte de sel
minéraux qui fait entrevoir un véritable
paysage lunaire des mines de sel gemme
sont en activité environ deux mois par
an
on trouve le chlorure de sodium informe
le christ au public blanc un ou deux
mètres de profondeur dans le sol dans
ses auteurs se trouve d'immenses lacs
peuplés de flamants roses ceylac
prennent des couleurs presque irréel à
cause de l'altitude
là
dans la pampa à l'intérieur du pays le
plaçant places séparées par des
centaines de kilomètres de désolation
existe des baraquements recouvert de
tôles ce sont des mines de cuivre
le travail est pénible archaïque
à une époque très reculées les indiens
chercher ici les turquoises qu'ils
cassaient avec un marteau de pierre que
l'on a retrouvée dans le désert
ils leur montrent est le minerai dans
une bourse en pot le minerai de cuivre
formant des filons se rencontrent à
toutes les profondeurs
il est en plus ou moins grande densité
ces petits artisans vendent le minerais
tels quels coupé en petits morceaux
tout à côté le modernisme et
l'industrialisation ont fait leur
apparition
une des plus grandes et les plus riches
mines de cuivre du monde fou tout cas
madhta en plein désert ces mines produit
50 mille tonnes de cuivre pur par jour
elles font vivre trente mille personnes
avec ses 6000 ouvriers et employés
la mine à ciel ouvert forme un cirque de
2700 mètres de long pour 1800 de large
et 300 mètres de profondeur
le minerai et exprès à la dynamique
le minerai et charles sur les trains
électriques qui circulent sur 133 km de
voies ferrées
chaque wagon transport 70 kg de minerai
brut
trente trois locomotives amène le
minerai à pied d'oeuvre pour être
traités dans une usine ultra moderne
lui jean du traitement par oxydation est
une des meilleures du monde
la solution est ensuite versé dans des
bars où 30 des plates formes en cathode
on y envoie le courant électrique
décompose la solution et le cuivre
qu'elle contient va adhérer au cathode
celles ci on sort du bain avec un poids
supplémentaire de 68 kg formé par le
cuivre puce
le tout est pensé en trois fours amadou
sy fendue
il
le cuivre écoulée pour obtenir sa forme
commerciale
le sous sol contient bien d'autres
retouches néanmoins estimable le nitrate
est lui aussi extrait à ciel ouvert aux
premiers stades le minerai se nomme
kalisz
le khalife est ensuite pulvérisé puis
mélangée à de l'eau chaude qui dissout
le nitrate et forme une pulpe qui est
filtrée dans le calife on rencontre une
certaine quantité de sel diodes on les
traite avec des gaz sulfureux qui
réduisent les iodes des formes
finalement de lieux d'élémentaire llyod
obtenu par filtration est transformé en
sublimer dans des corps nus sorte de
four est ensuite livrée dans le commerce
dans ce pays le volcan où la terre n'est
jamais très stable un peu partout maïs
des sources d'eau chaude la surface du
sol présente d'innombrables troubles
grandeurs différentes dans lesquels de
l'eau bouillonne continuellement
l'eau qui s'écoule du trou abandonne un
dépôt minéral siliceux très abondants et
très colorés
par instants l'eau jaillit du sol à
plusieurs mètres de hauteur et dégage
une quantité considérable de vapeur
d'eau dans ces régions volcaniques ces
geysers sont une relation évidente avec
la permanence de l'activité interne
je
irène chagnaud vous a proposé un voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec des films de gilbert le
montage rené gary script jacqueline
noirs sont maurice tboul jean poliquin
poids une façon selon dominic palladini
réalisation solange péters